you're a very broad human hmm because I
think somebody can be introduced to you
by one thing like I knew you for comedy
and stand-up comedy and your videos and
then all of a sudden i watch [ __ ] and
you know I've been an acting class for
years and years and years and I watch
your performance and I'm not just trying
to blow smoke up your ass it was amazing
I don't think the movie was great and
then also I would I was like he sings
and your sing really well so then you're
a singer and then I was telling Meg on
the way here I was like David's kind of
like who I would be in another life
because I love matcha I would own sip I
would own my own ice cream shop and then
I would be in this amazing indie movie
and a singer I'm like we are the same
person but you do all these different
things I mean how do you balance that
and even with [ __ ] like that was such a
specific movie what if you got something
that required such a different skill set
of you I mean I just don't think I care
about failing that's why like I just
don't give a [ __ ] this is one of those
relevant filming about anything if I
[ __ ] fail I fail Oh cares right
because that's that's just something I
had to learn and I talked about this on
the last podcast and it started when I
was really young I used to be very
scared of everything
my dad hated that about me he [ __ ]
hated that about me he hated the fact
that I couldn't go up and order my own
food at a [ __ ] McDonald's because I
was so scared of interacting with people
and my dad hated that he used to [ __ ]
beat my ass because I just was such a
timid little kid I just would not
interact with human beings like I liked
talking I was a class clown but that was
just a way for me to try to divert my
nervousness right and after a while I
think I honestly say it has to start
it's probably started really around like
my junior of high school and then from
then on it just got better and better
and better and then so my junior year of
high school when I was younger I was so
scared of like people's perception of me
right I didn't I didn't join quiet till
I was a senior and I wanted to join
choir when I was a freshman that is so
surprising to hear yeah so I just didn't
want to do it because I was scared of
what people thought about me I don't
my friends call me a [ __ ] they did but
seeking your who the [ __ ] cares I'm
leaving anyways right I'm gonna leave
I'm gonna go to college [ __ ] all you
guys and in that moment my senior year
of high school was the happiest that I
ever was in my 4 years of high school
because I didn't care I just didn't care
anymore I figured out how to study I
figured out how to read a [ __ ] book
you know what I mean and when when when
I started clicking these things together
I just started trying to implement that
every [ __ ] day and so now it's just
evolved into something where I try it
out and if it doesn't work it doesn't
[ __ ] work this podcast everybody told
me not to do it they were like don't do
a podcast you're gonna kill your channel
I killed my channel but this podcast is
better than my channel now it was a big
[ __ ] risk the first few months there
wasn't a single cent coming to this
channel and I had to go without like
three or four months with no income you
know but I'd rather figure out what
happens if I fail than if I don't do it
and if it fails then I'll pick up my
pieces and I'll figure something else
out because in my mind
nothing's gonna [ __ ] stop me I'll
figure something else out I don't have
this thing of I'm scared to do something
because of what other people think or
what I feel about it so I like for
example um I had a relative that
graduated college he graduated and he
didn't this is something that I hate he
didn't want to take a part-time job
because he thought he was above it that
mentality pisses me off a lot because
for me I'll take anything if I don't
have something I will do whatever I can
to have that so if there's like a
certain level of life that I wanted to
achieve right let's say I needed to make
like seven or eight grand to live a
certain life right
I would work seven jobs just to get that
because that's what that situation I put
myself in like for somebody like that he
says I'm above driving for uber I'm
above doing this stuff because I am this
type of human being you don't really get
anywhere so for me I just don't care
about family I'll do anything I can to
get to what I want but once I get it I
shift a lot so that's that's a it's not
something I suggest people do but it's
just what makes me happy right so once I
did guk it's very hard for me to try to
work on another film now like I'm trying
my best but I'm not inspired to it's
it's I start writing and then I stop I
start writing in that I stop yeah when
it wasn't like that for that film but I
feel like for you you're such a
entrepreneur and your own person that I
feel like sometimes when you you are the
type of
and I would imagine would be in a movie
that you were a large part of the
creative process oh for sure because I
was talking to Khalif about auditioning
and he was telling me about when you
were going in for auditions and stuff
and thinking about you going into an
audition room just I don't know you very
well to be honest personally yeah even
though I hear about you a lot but and I
see your videos and stuff but just
thinking about you going into an
audition process because I I'm the
opposite of you in that sense and I I
mean I actually want to talk to you more
about how you can overcome that fear
because I care so much what people think
about me and I get so nervous of
performing even my singing teacher the
other day was telling me about this beta
blocker that some of her students are on
that kind of help calm your nerves and I
when talk to my doctor about this
because I get so much anxiety and she
said just because my body and different
things I can't take it but that's to the
point but when I go in and into an
audition I'm like oh my god please like
me and then I sit in the waiting room
and I see somebody that is like way
better than me in all these different
ways in my brain I'm like this person's
prettier they're skinnier they're taller
they're there are more Korean looking
they're less Korean looking they're
whatever and I just go crazy in my head
but I was like thinking about you in an
audition room and I'm like David
wouldn't care and he wouldn't oh I
absolutely do not care I do it this way
and you didn't like that you know if the
casting director says do it a little bit
like this and I I don't really feel like
it fits the character the story I'll
just say okay well I want to make sure
she's like okay let's do it but I could
just see you being like um no this is
the way I see this person and I want to
be more like like how if you said that
swish and senior-year like what was it a
moment was it an event that happened or
was it kind of the span of you always
kind of just I'm gonna take another risk
and I'm gonna you just I think it's this
point where you kind of look at yourself
and you start hating yourself a little
bit like I I'm there it's uh I just you
know life is very short you know and you
know where I grew up too
there's a bunch of losers you know and I
I'm already past what I think that I was
already capable of when I was younger
which is crazy right so I had a
conversation with my fiancee she goes so
what are your goals I was like personal
goals I was like to be honest with you I
don't know like my I guess I have an
overarching goal which is just to be
happy and I do whatever I can to fill
that so I don't have this thing where I
can't it's a it's hard for me to stop
myself from doing something because of
something that I lack which is
completely within my control to not care
it's completely within your control
right so I get nervous on auditions
right I go in there but once it's done
it's out of my control it's a problem
for me when I see when people try to
control things that you cannot control
no matter what you [ __ ] do you cannot
control it so what's the whole point in
wasting your time thinking about it
nothing is gonna happen it's the same
advice that I give to these guys who are
afraid to approach women they go well
what happens nothing's gonna happen
you're not gonna [ __ ] die dude she's
gonna say no you might cry a little bit
but you'll [ __ ] live go for another
one and that's just how I approach
things now - even with these [ __ ]
auditions like I go in I try it out if I
get a callback
I do if I don't [ __ ] it what what who
cares I can only do the best that I can
do at the end of the day even on the
other side of like casting they're just
looking for the best person that fits
this role right or sometimes people just
suck a lot of dick and something happens
right and you know even with acting -
like I always say this it's really
something that's completely out of your
control is something that's out of the
casting directors control it's really
about who has the [ __ ] money right so
even even this when I was when I started
after I did Google I got to in I got to
speak to a lot of execs and what I
really found out just from talking to
people constantly and getting drinks
with them is that the casting directors
just opened the door like this and
that's as far as they can get it other
than that it's in everybody else's hands
the director depends on how much power
the director has who the director is if
it's not them then it'll be up to the
network there's a network like you
enough right do they want to put their
money behind you sometimes and I say
about in my personal opinion from what
I've seen and what I've heard seventy
percent the time they've already casted
who they want you
the backup to the backup mm-hmm so you
you already had the chip stacked against
you and in your cases specifically
because you're an actor that's also the
life that you chose so if you're
choosing this [ __ ] life you have to
expect that out of everything that's
gonna happen I always tell people with
acting is like going into a [ __ ] job
interview [ __ ] 12 times a week for
the rest of your [ __ ] life and having
every person tell you that you're not
good enough yeah you know that sounds
pretty active yeah you know what I mean
and sometimes these casting directors
don't even tell you what you did wrong
and you just have to mull over it at
home just god what did I do wrong you
don't [ __ ] know some of these catches
well they don't even [ __ ] tell you
that's how I feel when I get rejected
from clubs No okay go megwin hey megwin
- girl and dress right do I need to wear
more pink what did I do
yeah I couldn't get into any clubs in
Berlin when she went she was into one
club
it's called berghain it was notoriously
famous for not getting in mm-hmm
but yeah that's how my my experience
just had to wear like saran wrap as a
dressing I literally saw so many nipples
in that line like male and female
nipples with clothes like around them
but the nipples just completely exposed
yes well you had plenty of time while
waiting in line to fix your shirt I was
like wait anybody have some scissors
Larry off real quick and they just hang
in the clubs that girls like it's pretty
easy for a girl though that's what I
thought I'm a female done ya know so
just like casting Mike was walking away
from the club just wondering what was I
too tall was I what was it I wonder if
you just slowly started bringing your
dress down that rope would have just
opened up slowly
the amount of nipple you show it just
gives me opens my skirt was like going
higher and then I was like this is
ridiculous [ __ ] Club in like 3 or 4
years I been to maybe 3 clubs in mind
really but I was in Berlin yeah and
Berlin is the place where the